[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct avec nos partenaires
de la presse quotidienne régionale qui
sont co producteur de cette émission
ouest-france nice-matin france antilles
le groupe la montagne centre france 20
minutes également et puis le groupe
nice-matin bien sûr qui représentait
chaque fois par denis carot sur ce
plateau il sera avec nous dans quelques
instants mon invité et bien c'est
laurent berger bonjour laurent berger
bonjour de secrétaire général de la cfdt
les sujets ne manquent pas avec vous ce
matin bien sûr l'hôpital le pouvoir
d'achat les retraites l'état politique
du pays aussi et puis la représentation
syndicale ici dans notre pays en france
laurent berger vous êtes vous également
en campagne de réélection c'est beaucoup
dire en tout cas il ya un congrès la
semaine prochaine la calyon à lyon qui
arrivent tous les quatre ans et c'est le
moment où on fait le bilan notre
activité on voit si on a bien travaillé
certaine manière devant nos mandants
c'est à dire les syndicats
professionnels de partout partout en
france vous représentez lee et puis une
réélection de l'équipe dirigeante et je
me représente comme secrétaire général
congrès un problème pour vous passer le
bilan des quatre ans et 1600 délégués
2700 participants oui c'est un gros
événement sait jamais c'est pas un
problème la sévérité de la création qui
va bien qui fait face à ces responsables
concurrent solide à l'intérieur de la
confédération que ça fonctionne pas
vraiment comme ça chez nous il via des
débats sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui peuvent qui peuvent être sur la
table mais il n'y a pas ça et la cfdt
elle a une culture du débat interne qui
est une culture apaisé qui a une culture
exigeante et on se dit les choses mais
qui cherche l'efficacité notre
efficacité c'est quoi c'est d'être utile
aux travailleurs donc non ça se présente
bien mais j'avoue est un peu concentré
et un peu plus en tension et au stress
que des périodes habituelles c'est
normal c'est un congrès il faut il faut
le vivre pleinement et que ce soit de
bonne qualité et syndicats sont invités
à l'elysée demain à déjeuner je crois
vous y allez oui bien sûr c'est un
déjeuner de travail proposé par le
président de la république s'il martinez
n'y va pas lui oui c'est chacun si
j'étais voit midi à sa porte
moi je suis syndicaliste qui essaye de
faire avancer la situation des
travailleurs est le président de la
république c'est à dire celui qui quand
même pour l'instant dirige encore ce
pays si je puis dire et donc on y va
mais le reste ces considérations qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être pour moi il ya
nous on ira pour dire demain voilà
comment on voit les choses sur le
pouvoir d'achat voilà comment on voit
les choses sur le débat et la méthode et
puis et pousser nos propositions qu'on a
déjà remis à la première ministre vous
avez constamment ces derniers mois fait
part de votre inquiétude laurent berger
sur l'état du pays
la france est inquiète réellement est ce
que j'allais dire voulzy pouvais
quelquechose qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire vous quand on sait que la
représentation des syndicats dans ce
pays est en berne quand on sait que
l'état reste très centralisé très
interventionniste quand on sait qu'à une
situation mondiale problématique qu'est
ce que vous qu'est ce que est ce que les
gens peuvent encore placé leurs espoirs
dans un syndicalisme dans un syndicat et
on verra où du congrès mais toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion et on va en sortir
une au moment du congrès montrent que la
confiance dans les organisations
syndicales et particulièrement la cfdt
est en progression constante
la dernière enquête du cevipof tic les
orientations syndicales il ya 38 % de
deux citoyens qui qui qui leur font
confiance à retenir c'est que 38% mais
ces dix points aux 20 points au dessus
des politiques et d'histoire aux 20
points au dessus les médias lancé et
dont vous pouvez agir concrètement on
peut agir mais au loup mais on le fait
quand on obtient des augmentations
salariales la dernière exemple en date
c'est dans la propreté pour augmenter
les minimum de branche pour qu'ils
soient au dessus du smic on améliore la
situation concrète quand on se bat pour
de meilleures conditions de travail ou
des augmentations de salaires dans telle
ou telle entreprise on obtient les
avancées concrètes le problème si vous
voulez c'est ce que vous avez dit dans
votre question c'est l'hyper
centralisation on a l'impression que ce
qui n'existe en france et que 1
l'hypercentralisation sonore sénat
selick c'est pas ça serait trop facile
de le dire comme ça il y a une part de
responsabilité
c'est cette idée que nous ne pourrions
trouver les solutions aux préoccupations
que rencontrent les travailleurs et les
français qu'au niveau national avec des
grandes décisions et bien non ça ne se
passe pas comme ça il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se passent dans les
territoires dans les entreprises dans
les administrations
là où les gens vivent de là où les gens
vivent présence ce matin sur ce plateau
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt notre invité politique ce matin
d'en face aux territoires dans un
instant stéphane bern et de ouest france
est sur ce plateau avec moi
[Musique]
bonjour stéphane bern et vous avez un
grand chef délégué de ouest france et
direction en actions de paris nord ouest
france premier quotidien francophone du
monde dans un instant nous allons comme
interviewer laurent berger ensemble mais
françois-xavier le franc le rédacteur en
chef de ouest-france à une question à
vous poser depuis rennes et retraites
bien sûr calendrier méthodes on écoute
bonjour laurent berger emmanuel macron
annoncé une entrée en vigueur de la
réforme des retraites à l'été 2000 23 en
ce qui vous concerne vous avez fortement
énoncé votre opposition à la retraite à
65 ans est une mesure que vous
n'acceptez pas et vous dit aussi qu'il
n'y a pas urgence à réformer et pourtant
le système actuel s'il a bien les
qualités il a aussi quelques défauts
peut-être celui d'être inégalitaire
alors que faut-il faire faut-il réformer
si oui dans quel calendrier et surtout
avec quelle méthode
cfdt elle pense depuis longtemps qu'il
faut réformer le système de retraites
pour le rendre plus égale
davantage d'égalité c'est ce qui nous
avait poussés à dire on veut une réforme
systémique
on veut un système universel des
retraites vous savez qu'il ya une
tentative en 2019 qui a avorté pour deux
raisons qu'à apporter d'abord parce
qu'on a mis des éléments paramétrique
avec ce fameux âge pivot dans la dans la
réforme puis l'a emporté parce qu'il ya
une copie des on a tout stoppé mais
dorian donc deux questions c'est moi je
veux savoir ce qui est dans la tête de
ceux qui nous gouvernent sur cette
réforme des retraites si c'est une
logique purement paramétrique de report
de l'âge légal pour nous c'est
fondamentalement injuste c'est injuste
pourquoi ça va toucher ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt ceux qui ont
des carrières pénibles et ceux qui
cotisent déjà sur le temps nécessaire
mais qui vont être obligés d'aller
jusqu'à 64 65 ans si la finalité c'est
juste ça oui la cfdt est opposé si il y
a derrière une réforme des retraites qui
se ferait qui serait sûr on améliore la
situation des femmes de ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées on met des vraies
mesures de pénibilité des mesures de on
accentue les mesures de carrés pour
carrière longue c'est qu'on parle des
fins de carrière de l'emploi des seniors
car on sera autour de la table mais pas
pour une mesure purement paramétrer
physiquement mais si vous posez la
question c'est à dire que vous n'avez
pas de réponse vous ne savez toujours
pas sur quelle base le pouvaient les
pouvoirs publics le gouvernement veut
négocier pour l'instant on a le sujet
des retraites dans notre pays on a
l'impression pour l'instant que les
slogans contre slogan avec des âges le
sujet des retraites c'est bien plus
sérieux ça quand on parle de terre ton
par le travail on parle fin de carrière
on parle pour faut qu'on s'interroge
pourquoi les gens autant à vis de partir
aussi vite à la retraite tout simplement
dans la méthode assez mal le les fans
carrière dans la méthode ccc relâche de
revivre l'instant j'en ai fait une
raison mais c'est du couple c'est
sérieux de dire je veux que cette
réforme entre en vigueur à l'été 2000 23
dessus mais c'est une date butoir et
vous savez alors que finalement il n'y a
aucune base de la méthode qui me
semblerait la plus efficace c'est à dire
voilà je pense qu'il ya besoin d'une
réforme des retraites et voilà pourquoi
je pense qu'il ya besoin d'une réforme
des retraites nous à cfdt si je dis
qu'il ya réforme des retraites c'est sûr
améliorer la justice sociale au sein du
système des retraites ce qu'on sent ça a
été dit pendant la campagne c'est que la
proche par le président de la république
aujourd'hui elle est purement
paramétrique avec le report de l'âge là
je le dit c'est new way pour le cdt nos
pas de possibilités ça c'est une mesure
injuste pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes je le redis est ce
qu'on est carrière penny et dire à la
date d'application avant même de dire
c'est quoi la finalité est ce que c'est
pour équilibrer les comptes des régimes
de retraite il n'y a pas un gros
problème d'équilibré des comptes des
régimes de retraite là le corps le
montrera sans doute l'homme dans son
prochain rapport encore c'est pas
fondamental comme ça l'était en 2003 en
2013 est ce que c'est pour financer
d'autres politiques publiques
l'éducation la santé qui ont bien besoin
est là rodino pour financer des
politiques publiques de ce style et ya
besoin de financer d'investir
massivement dans l'éducation massivement
dans la santé on le sait il y a un autre
effet mécanisme qui existe qui s'appelle
la fiscalité et c'est pas en reportant
l'âge légal de départ en retraite qu'on
finance la perte d'autonomie qu'on
finance l'éducation la santé et ça on
sera en désaccord sur la philosophie
même donc on va attendre de voir il n'y
a pas urgence pour discuter de ça je
crois qu'il ya des sujets pro pouvoir
d'achat et le budget annoncé service
public mais de les retraites on verra
mais il faudra que le gouvernement
éclaircisse ses objectifs sur les
mesures prises pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat quel est votre regard il ya le
chèque alimentaire qui va venir les
aides à la pompe le bouclier tarifaire
il ya des propositions sur des blocages
des loyers ou des prix deux premiers de
produits de première nécessité est ce
que tout ça est pas de nature à occulter
le un autre problème de fond qui est
celui de l'augmentation des salaires
niveau général des salaires quelle est
votre position la position c'est que
vous le dit très bien le pouvoir d'achat
et nous on préfère parler de pouvoir de
vivre parce que c'est aussi de vivre
décemment mais il implique des questions
de dépenses et notamment de dépenses
contraintes et on le sait l'inflation ça
pèse davantage sur les ménages les plus
modestes donc il va falloir des mesures
davantage ciblés on va pas rose et le
sable c'est pas pareil de prendre sa
voiture pour partir en week-end sur à
l'ouest dans l'ouest par exemple le
week-end que d'aller tous les jours pour
travailler dans son usine
agroalimentaire ou dans sa collectivité
de faire 30 ou 20 ou 35 km donc il faut
des mesures ciblées c'est ce qu'on dit
sur l'alimentation et notamment à
destination des ménages les plus
modestes mais pouvoir d'achat c'est ce
qu'on reçoit de son travail et les
négociations sur les négociations sur
les salaires et bien il y en a eu ça a
été assez on a poussé ça fait maintenant
six ou dix huit mois qu'on pousse
notamment pour les scones a qualifié les
travailleurs est essentielle il ya eu
des avancées mais c'est vite grignotée
par l'inflation et la roma il ya des
besoins d'augmentation de salaire il ya
un besoin à la fois conjoncturelle les
ont écrits sont raides et pour lutter
contre la déflation dans certaines
entreprises oui clairement les quelques
temps aux autres les grandes entreprises
elles dont toutes celles qui tique dont
les marges ont été restaurés et et se
porte bien dans celle ci il ya une
question structurelle de partage de la
valeur et elles jouent le jeu et pas
toutes pas tout et elles jouent pas le
jeu notamment à l'égard de leurs sous
traitants elles jouent pas toujours le
jeu à l'égard de leurs salariés mais le
problème qui est posé c'est la toute
récente à vis de la valeur sur
l'ensemble de la semaine par exemple
dans une entreprise industrielle un site
industriel quand vous faites une
augmentation salariale le monsieur où la
dame qui est dans la guérite de la
sécurité pour faire passer et ben elle a
pas d'augmentation de salaire alors de
remous il faut les augmentations de
salaires c'est clair il ya des logiques
de dirt partage de la valeur qu'il faut
restaurer et puis je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrête avec les minimum de branche
qui sont en dessous du smic alors entre
ceux qui jouent le jeu et jouent pas le
jeu il ya un bon exemple c'est la prime
la fameuse prime macron le résident la
république a annoncé qu'elle serait
triplé s'il était réélu il est réélu
est-ce qu'elle marche cette prime est ce
que tout le monde en bénéficie oui ce
qu'il ya pas d inégalités les injustices
en la matière tout le monde bénéficie
pas on le sait et vous avez un rôle par
rapport à ça
djibrine aux équipes font pression dans
les entreprises pour des augmentations
de salaire pour la prime à certains
moments est ce qu'il faut dire sur cette
prime c'est que le gouvernement au près
dans la pub peut dire le montant qu'il
veut c'est un libre choix de leur ligne
à l'employeur est donc clairement il
faut que les entreprises jouent le jeu
des entreprises il ya deux types
d'entreprises à celles qu'ont des marges
et qui doivent répartir la richesse par
les augmentations de salaires et celles
qui ont plus de difficultés celle-ci et
doivent trouver les mécanismes
d'augmentation de salaire est couplé
avec le mécanisme de primes et des
clauses de revoyure pour que on voit à
la fin de l'année si l'inflation est
toujours dur à mais on a un vrai
problème aujourd'hui de gagner sa vie
décemment pour nombre de travailleurs
pas tout ça il faut le dire aussi à
partir de son travail très vite j'ai
envie d'y jouer plus générale le feu le
président de la république a dit que ce
serait un ce serait un nouveau
quinquennat qui sera un nouveau
président qu'il allait changer de
méthode est-ce qu'il a changé est ce
qu'il va changer est-ce qu'il peut
changer pour de vrai un nouveau on verra
aux actes on jugera aux actes vous avez
laissé bien depuis longtemps oui je le
connais évidemment depuis longtemps on
est arrivé aux affaires jugées
respectivement à peu près au même moment
et je pense qu'on jugera aux actes c'est
la méthode c'est pas que de l' écoute
c'est aussi de la co construction et
c'est prendre la température du pays qui
mieux que les organismes syndicale les
élus locaux les associations sont en
capacité de lui dire un peu la
température du pays personne sauf qu'il
va falloir qu'ils nous écoutent
davantage et qui ou écoutent aussi nos
revendications voilà chaunu qui est
dessinateur et collaborateurs de ouest
france à une question à vous poser c'est
un peu la tradition dans cette émission
laurent berger sous forme de dessin on
écoute il s'agit d'un pot de départ
bientôt pas pour vous
bonjour qu'est ce que j'apprends tous
les syndicats sont invités vendredi à
déjeuner à l'elysée à la veille du
premier tour des législatives
le président n'est certes il pas de vous
faire avaler un plat un peu trop salée
vous qu'elle est pourtant l'enfant de
gerrans alors le week-end dernier nous
avons tous été
ému et un brin jaloux en voyant tout un
peuple célébrer le jubilé de sa reine
avec une petite pensée pour le prince
charles qui n'en finit plus d'attendre
que sa mère partent en retraite
la normandie elle a fêté le 78ème
anniversaire du d-day et jean luc
mélenchon rêve de débarquer elisabeth
bornes et bien pour décrocher un job à
matignon à 70 ans alors la question que
je pose
qu'allez vous offrir au pot de départ en
retraite de votre pote de la cgt
philippe martin est
arrivé pas partir en retraite 1 s'est il
par pas en retraite d'ailleurs d'après
ce que j'ai compris lorsque et qui fera
sa responsabilité parce qu'il aura
encore à travailler
je ne sais pas je lui offrir je lui
offrira un verre déjà parce qu'on a de
bonnes relations là les relations
interpersonnelles et pas la guerre oui
c'est pas la guerre c'est ça se passe
normalement dans
dans le respect mutuel je sais pas j ai
pas réfléchi encore ce que c'est un peu
lointain mais sans doute peut-être
peut-être un livre qui parle de
l'évolution syndicale moi je suis très
fier que mon organisation syndicale
pendant que j'étais responsable soit
devenue la première organisation
syndicale française dont l'arrêté un
deuil ou grâce à petit j'en serais je
vais vous dire il verrier vient de
quitter la responsabilité de morceaux
ouvrière philippe martinez
va le faire je le ferai aussi je ferai
pas tout le monde a gelé dit même si je
me représente
oui on a de bonnes relations j'ai du
respect et je n'aime pas attaquer les
gens et franchement j'ai on a pas de
relation et j'ai du respect pour ces
pour mes collègues la une de ouest
france très vite l'interdiction des
ventes de voitures neuves essence et
diesel d'ici 2035 merci stéphane dernier
rédacteur en chef délégué de ouest
france directeur de la rédaction du
bureau de paris merci à vous on continue
dans un instant denis carot de nice
matin sur ses plateaux
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot au jour dans un
instant qu interview vrai avec moi
laurent berger notre invité ce matin
d'en face aux territoires le secrétaire
général de la cfdt met tout de suite
notre partenaire cyril boutier directeur
éditorial de france antilles à une
question à vous poser laurent berger
depuis fort-de-france en l'écoutent
bonjour laurent berger aux antilles et
en guyane les intersyndicales de la
santé réclament la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés qui ont été
suspendus dans une interview à la presse
quotidienne régionale et singulièrement
dans nos colonnes ce week-end le
président de la république a dit
attendre le feu vert des autorités
scientifiques
selon vous que faut-il faire les
réintégrer peut-être ainsi soulager le
manque de personnel à l'hôpital ou
attendre dans le doubs de savoir si
cette réintégration pourrait ou non
influer sur l'épidémie à la réponse très
courte mais très clair d'abord il ya un
sujet serait spécifique aux antilles et
en guyane cake exposé très différemment
dans l'hexagone est très clairement je
crois que c'est les autorités
scientifiques qui doivent répondre à ce
problème là le coc vide il n'est pas
derrière nous et je tiens à le dire il
ya de nouveau un petit rebond est donc
il ya ce sujet là qu'est posée je ne
crois pas que ce soit je crois pas qu'il
faille de près le traité de
précipitamment faut attendre que les
autorités sanitaires pluie pour que
l'épidémie ne se ne se répande pas
davantage au corps sujet l'hôpital denis
caron toujours sur la santé des services
d'urgence on le voit tous les jours sont
au bord de l'explosion 120 sont en
grande difficulté en france emmanuel
macron annoncé qu'il allait lancer une
mission flash avec des décisions dès
juillet la ministre de la santé brigitte
bourguignon a annoncé hier une première
série de mesures avec notamment les
heures supplémentaires payées double et
le recours aux soignants retraité est ce
que ces réponses sont à la hauteur de
l'enjeu d'abord moi je suis très en
colère sur la question d'hôpital parce
que ça fait des années et des années
qu'on dit que moi j'avais même écrit en
2000 2015 que l'hôpital était au bord du
burn au bord du burn out en fait on y
est donc on n'a pas suffisamment
anticipé maintenant on est dans
l'urgence je crois pas que leur il est
tellement sûrs à l'étude de ce qui se
passe on le sait très bien il ya un
manque de professionnels des gens qui
partent parce qu'ils ont peur plus de
leurs conditions de travail eman al
maqtari par les situations sont
différentes selon les occasions sont en
rien n'arrive à roth mais on a toujours
les logiques de de circularisation et
tout le monde la fonction départ est
donc les solutions pour la cgt c'est en
partie traités hôpital par hôpital par
le dialogue professionnel avec les
soignants qui savent très bien comment
il pourrait faire parce qu'ils l'ont
fait pendant qu'on vide comment on
pourrait organiser les choses la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya besoin
d'investissements massifs il ya besoin
d'organiser le système de soins
autrement il ya trop peu de médecins
généralistes qui au fond des gardois
recrutement massif il faudra des
recrutements massifs moi je ne me
déplace dans aucun hôpital où on me dit
pas qu'il manque 30 20 30 50 60 80
soignants donc il faut des recrutements
massifs mais là on à l'urgence de cet
été l'urgence de cet été c'est
travailler avec les soignants ya des
soignants qui apprennent par circulaire
qui vont avoir que 15 jours de congés
c'est pas pareil si on discute de
comment avoir organisé l'été
et on les considère un peu plus il va
falloir clairement que la médecine de
ville s'y mettent pendant l'été il va
falloir organiser du système de sous le
système de soins c'est pas normal que
tous ceux qui viennent aux urgences
soient obligés d'aller aux urgences qui
n'a pas d'autre alternative expliquer ça
à vos adhérents ils ne comprennent ils
le comprennent tout cas ils sont tout à
fait conscients observer la question du
désert des déserts médicaux est un vrai
sujet et le fait que lorsqu'on a un
petit problème aimé qu'on pourrait se
passer d urgence on n'a pas d'autre
alternative que d'aller aux urgences
parce qu'il n'ya pas de permanence de
soi ça pose un vrai problème et c'est ça
qui englue en partie le le le les
urgences il ya deux ans fait il ya deux
angles d'attaqué il va falloir faire
face à l'été fort face à sale et et moi
je comprends qu'un certain nombre de
mesures gens ce qu'ils soient prêts
qu'ils soient prises et puis
structurellement l'hôpital va falloir
investir se dire que c'est pas un coup
c'est d'abord une richesse ans il ya eu
l'heureuse élue t il ya eu le ségur de
la santé on peut pas dire qu'on mais on
s'en félicite et on est à participer le
ségur de la santé c'est une
revalorisation une reconnaissance des
professionnels à travers une
revalorisation salariale très importante
et c'est très bien ça veut pas dire
qu'on est au bout de ces trois le réseau
social mais c'est très bien mais dans le
ségur de la santé il ya aussi un volet
qualitatif qui était en fait davantage
on travaille sur l'organisation des
soins on travaille sur les coudes des
salariés des agents de la fonction
publique hospitalière ce qui n'est pas
suffisamment fait aujourd'hui et on a
des plans de recrutement massif on a un
problème aujourd'hui de formation on a
un problème de recrutement donc il faut
des mesures d'urgence et fo durablement
pendant tout le quinquennat investir
massivement dans la santé alors je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la méthode
emmanuel macron vous l'appeliez au
lendemain de son de sa réélection à
associer le plus grand nombre la
co-construction de décision est-ce que
sa décision de créer un conseil national
de la refondation qui va associer des
associations des élus locaux les
syndicats des citoyens est ce que ça va
dans le bon sens est ce que c'est une
réponse on peut pas rejeter d'un revers
de main ce qui a été annoncé ce week end
avec ce conseil national le raf
fondation on peut discuter sur le nom
sur l'acronyme etc mais on peut pas
rejeter d'un revers de main à
l'intention mais l'intention ne fait pas
l'acte ait l'intention ne dit pas la
façon dont ça fonctionne moi je ne crois
pas personnellement qu'il faut recréer
une structure supplémentaire je crois
qu'il faut avoir en intégrer la logique
de la co construction et la du dialogue
permanent à travers toutes les instances
qui existe déjà est ce que vous craignez
que les cas soient soient noyés dans la
masse
ça sera sujet par sujet si vous parlez
de l'organisation du système de soins et
de la santé et bien c'est normal qu'ils
aient les collectivités territoriales
qui est des associations d'usagers qu'il
ya des syndicats etc si vous parlez des
retraites c'est clairement le monde
économique et social qui doit traiter
cette question là c'est pas dans ceux
ses nerfs si c'est une nouvelle
structure un peu lourdes où tout le
monde y est et tous les sujets arrivent
ça marchera pas si c'est un là une forme
de label pour dire voilà à chaque
décision publique on aura pris le temps
de la concertation de l'écouté des uns
et des autres et de répondre aux
propositions et revendications
ce sera autre chose donc c'est ça que je
veux éclaircir demain avec le président
de la république pour savoir ce qu'il ya
derrière est juge de ça ça veut déjeuner
de travail demain à l'elysée il ya une
instance qui existe un et qui est censé
mettre du lien entre les syndicats et
les citoyens c'est le conseil économique
et social environnemental ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut le fermer non pas du
tout c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
la vision mais encore une fois j'ai lu
comme vous l'a les interviews dans la
pqr et j'en sais pas plus la vision que
je porte classés 8es porte c'est plutôt
d'avoir une logique de hockey dialogue à
tous les étages concertation
éco-construction à tous les étages mais
on laisse les structures en place pour
ce dépôt mais pour imposer l'idée qu'
elles tiennent leur rôle pleinement et
on les écoute donc l'idée c'est pas un
super machin qu'on marque créée par
dessus ça c'est l'un de ses mandats le
supermaché coûté pour l'instant quand je
oui j'ai lu et relu l'interview je n'en
sais pas plus mais si c'est pour faire
il ya des gars et vous avez oublié de
citer aussi à commissariat général au
plan donc en fait eu nos structures moi
je crois que c'est plutôt une
philosophie et une façon de faire qu'il
faut bouger que l'une créer une
structure dans la question denis carot
elisabeth bornes et olivier du socle
nouveau ministre du travail ce sera de
bon interlocuteur pour vous d'abord on
les choisit pas nos interlocuteurs se
calquant ses coordonnées oui vous les
aviez pratiquant les réserves quand on
est représentant dans une entreprise
revenant au syndicat ne choisit pas son
patron quand on est responsable national
cet été on ne choisit pas ses
interlocuteurs gouvernementaux
élise avait deux bornes davantage c'est
que on peut avoir discussion cash y
compris en termes de désaccord et on
s'est focalisé qu'elle écoute davantage
écoutés quand je les rencontre et comme
première ministre je peux vous dire que
j'ai trouvé très à l'écouté on lui a
remis à
plus que lorsqu'on position du travail
quelques semaines d'arrêt c'est pas moi
je suis très sensible aux changements de
posture et c'est le cas elle a changé
par rapport aux non mais elle était on a
discuté quand l'été vous savez là pardon
envers les autres dans un période
coville il faut le dire on a beaucoup
discuté beaucoup apporté beaucoup
trouver une solution parce que les
orientations syndicales en apportait
quand vous regardez j'ai trouvé à
l'écouté c'est une première rencontre on
lui a remis toutes nos propositions et
maintenant encore une fois c'est moi je
ne pas juger les gens à l'instant t et
les ah il va falloir juger sur pièce et
on est dans l'espèce d'entre deux ans
pour ben avoir dit cela tire on verra
après elle a une de nice-matin denis
carot un nouveau record du prix des
carburants qui atteindra un niveau
inédit on met en perspective avec la
décision du parlement européen
d'interdire les véhicules thermiques dès
2035 douala denis carot directeur de la
rédaction du groupe nice-matin co
producteur de cette émission merci dans
un instant armelle le goff de 20 minutes
sur ce plateau avec moi
[Musique]
et avec moi pourquoi interviewer laurent
berger armelle le goff vous êtes la
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
alors notre partenaire du groupe centre
france la montagne
cette semaine c'est l'yonne républicaine
c'est un des quotidiens de ceux de ce
groupe la montagne centre france myriam
le bret qui est journaliste depuis
auxerre à une question à vous poser
laurent berger ont l'écoutent pouvoir
d'achat ses modalités
bonjour laurent berger l'inflation
s'établit à 5,2 pour cent en mai sur un
an selon l'estimation provisoire
récemment publiées par l'insee et ce
après des hausses déjà conséquente sur
les mois précédents la hausse des prix
s'installe dans la durée quels sont
selon vous les solutions qui pourraient
être envisagées pour préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des français et le
chèque alimentaire est il une bonne idée
tel qu'il est présenté par le
gouvernement
les mesures c'est gelé déjà dit des
mesures précises les mois les ménages
les plus modestes je pense que il faut
l'inflation vous savez c'est pas qu'une
mesure économique c'est des conséquences
sociales très très lourde sur les
ménages les plus modestes c'était vers
ceux qui sont contraints quand un poids
avec des dépenses contraintes très
important dans leurs dépenses et c'est
donc des mesures ciblées en termes
aliments chèques alimentaires chèque
énergie dead à la mobilité aux
déplacements mais je crois qu'à un
moment donné on va avoir besoin de
ressources supplémentaires au dire des
choses pour financer ses politiques
l'âme et l'inflation ça touche pas de
tout le monde la même manière notamment
ta touche pas les ménages les plus aisés
et das trouve pas les très riches et il
y en a ça veut dire qu'il faut
transformer l'imposition je pense je
pense qu à qu'on passera pas à côté d'un
débat sur la fiscalité dans notre pays
la fiscalité des entreprises ou les
niches la fiscalité des ménages la
fiscalité du capital pour le mettre au
même niveau que la fiscalité des revenus
du travail la question des transmissions
il ya 50 % du patrimoine car si les
mesures qui est également mal vue par
les français et même pas les ménages
finalement oui mais oui a transmis oui
mais c'est parce que on dit pas les
choses comme il faut comme il faut c'est
à dire que la transmission moyenne de
mémoire je crois pour reposer ses
ennemis ses vingt mille euros et donc
vingt mille euros il n'y a pas de
taxation mais 50% du patrimoine je le
répète est détenu par dix pour cent des
français avec la transmission qui se
fait à coup très très très limité et
bien c'est ça qu'il faut fait peut-être
finances et qui peut peut-être perdre
par exemple servir à financer la perte
d'autonomie on fera pas l'économie
l'inflation il faut le dire on a le
sentiment que ça touche tout le monde la
même manière c'est pas vrai ça touche
d'abord les ménages les plus modestes
des mesures ciblées et une contribution
plus importante des très très riche et
il y en a quand même fou dit souvent que
le climat ont bien aujourd'hui vous
inquiète pourquoi justement à cause de
ça ces questions parce que pour pour pas
simplement d'abord là on à l'inflation
on a on est en face on fait face à des
problèmes concrets très concrets pour
nombre de citoyens et de travailleurs et
en même temps on a des défis de moyen et
long terme qui sont monumentaux et je
pense notamment la transition écologique
et il ya une forte angoisse qui saisit
le pays les inégalités la difficulté à
pouvoir vivre correctement et en même
temps une perspective qui est
inquiétante et on voit pas trop comment
on là qu'on n'a pas assez
d'investissements la transition
écologique et la bonne décision côté
plaisir en europe mais mais mais ça va
pas assez vite ça c'est forme d'angoissé
et de l'autre côté un débat public qui
est excusez moi de le dire un peu
oui par te manquer dégueulasse où il
faut
une espèce de disqualification
systématique de son interlocuteur fans
excusez moi de vous le dire regardez ce
qui se passe sur le débat sur
législatives en fait ce qui est plus
important c'est dégommer celui ou celle
qui a en face qui pensent pas comme vous
que de faire vos propositions et donc il
faut revenir à un peu d'apaisement dans
le débat qui est responsable les
politiques dans cette affaire à moi je
pense que tous ceux qui pensent que
émettre un avis c'est d'abord tapé sur
celui qui n'est pas d'accord avec lui
fait du mal à la démocratie je pense que
la démocratie c'est la capacité à faire
se confronter pacifiquement des athées
des visions contradictoires hadassah des
râles des réseaux sociaux de ce point de
vue là je ne me suis pas un adepte des
réseaux sociaux je pense que les réseaux
sociaux font du mal ça peut ça pourrait
être quelque chose de formidable salle
est parfois en termes d'entrées en
termes de connaissances etc mais moi je
vais vous le dire puisque je suis face à
des journalistes on met pas assez en
avant ce qui se passe de beaux de bien
dans l'est par les acteurs associatifs
syndicaux et élus locaux etc dans les
territoires on le fait pas assez moi je
suis à la tête d'un pqr je le dis
franchement je suis un enfant d'ouest
avec vous êtes bienvenu sur les plateaux
gratuite et de la plage gratuite
et de la presse en général de toute
façon mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que je je je pense qu'il faut
qu'on remette de l'apaisement dans le
débat public ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y
pas de l'exigence et le maquereau le
félin comme étant ton quand on met en
place des conventions citoyenne après un
mouvement comme les gilet jaune par
exemple est ce que vous pourriez revenir
comment vous avez vécu ce mouvement
qu'il ya une explosion de colère
justement le moment si le mouvement ils
essayent ils avaient d d d d d d
fondement réel qu'on avait soulevé
depuis longtemps et on avait dit au près
dans la république et à d'autres il ya
un problème il ya un problème de deux de
ces personnes qui n'ont plus le pouvoir
de vivre décemment que leur apportent
leurs revenus du travail qu'on le
sentiment des délaissés en fer avec des
services publics qui les délaisse pas
qu'il est ds qui ont disparu etc les
soubassements du mouvement des gilet
jaune on était quand même très pour nous
on était très questionnant et nous ont
un peu rebuté sont encore là ces sous
bassement aujourd'hui et vous des
exceptions revenir enfin pas pour tout
le monde mais clairement le souffle le
soubassement sur sociale les raisons
sociales c'est-à-dire ce sentiment ne
pas avoir des dans un désert médical de
ne pas avoir de quoi vivre correctement
tard ils sont toujours là le ce qu'il
faut c'est transformé c'est qui ces
réalités là on solution et pas en
éruption c'est sale c'est ça l'enjeu du
politique aujourd'hui est l'enjeu des
acteurs et nous on veut y participer à
une seule condition c'est qu'on nous ait
bien que souvent vous interpelle sur le
fait de rentrer en politique est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez que vous avez
été la bonne place pour changer les
choses oui je crois que je suis lire
quand je crois que je suis à la bonne
place et je crois que les organisations
syndicales les élus locaux les
associations ne sont pas ceux qu'on
appelle les corps intermédiaires ne sont
pas assez écoutés dans notre pays et que
c'est aussi par là qu'on change les
choses on ne changera pas les choses que
par les grandes lois et les grandes
mesures nationales vers je le fais au
site est le rempart emmanuel l'action
concrète et dernier déplacement du
président de la république sur des
thématiques 1 la santé à cherbourg de
l'éducation à marseille 3-1 jeunesse à
clichy-sous-bois 4 la sécurité à gaillac
seul il est seul
chaque fois il est seul sur ses
déplacements thématiques est ce que
c'est la solution aux questions que vous
posez non mais je ne crois pas là c'est
une campagne chacun fait sa campagne
comme il veut mais je crois est ce que
pour ce nom ces normes résoudra pas ce
qu'elle veut mais moi je crois qu'il
faut davantage faire confiance aux
acteurs et c'est dans les territoires
qu'on trouvera les solutions y compris
sur la transition écologique mais sur la
lutte contre les inégalités sur la toile
et c'est l'année de mariée que vous
contestez mais ce serait trop facile
parce que ça n'a jamais ça à tout ça a
souvent été comme ça je crois qu'il a
accentué par sa personnalité ce
phénomène là mais je crois que ce serait
trop facile de polariser moi vous savez
mon combat il n'est pas contre quelqu'un
il est pur il est pour la démocratie il
est pour la situation des travailleurs
il est pour beaucoup davantage de
justice sociale pour une vraie
transition écologique wee cc un seul
problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut
taper sur quelqu'un pour faire croire
qu'on existe qu'est ce qu'il faut
souhaiter une cohabitation par exemple
là on est à la v60 ses citoyens qu'ils
choisiront est-ce que ça permettrait pas
justement de résoudre
stabilisation c'est sympa il ya on en a
eu plusieurs expériences dans la vème
république
ça n'a pas été que des périodes ni
négative ni positif ça a été des
périodes convient qu'on existait il ya
eu des très belles choses qui ont été
faites par les périodes de cohabitation
sapeurs et les citoyens qui choisissent
ces citoyens qui est la une vous vous
entendez bien avec geoffroy roux de
bézieux on a deux pareils on est dans le
respect on n'est pas dans l'accord
évidemment vous dans un portrait une
part de lui est engagé dans son
organisation et une part de son cerveau
est mise à la disposition du pays vos
trucs ça vous défini ouais je crois moi
je suis pas je n'aime pas être seulement
sous une bannière je compte j'espère
m'être utile à tous la une de 20minutes
sur l' angoisse du justement de la
majorité des manuels macro et 2 et des
menus des d'elisabeth bornes sur les
résultats des élections législatives
l'ombre d'un doute joli titre merci
armelle le goff et actrices de la
rédaction de 20 minutes je rappelle que
c'est une un partenariat entre la voix
du nord et ouest france que vous dirigez
merci dans un instant des maîtres
korkmaz de tv5 monde sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour dit m merci d'être avec nous ce
matin donc on démarre cette europe
sociale absolument et ce sur le salaire
minimum l'europe a adopté un cadre
commun mais ça n'est qu'un cadre commun
c'est presque un esprit on dira pas de
cadre contraignant donc parfois on se
demande si vraiment cette europe sociale
a une utilité vous savez que vous parlez
aux prêts dont la conférence européenne
des syndicats on le dit pas assez en
france d'ailleurs on met pas assez
l'europe en avant très clairement s'ils
n'existaient pour exposer les
difficultés moi je peux vous dire que
j'ai mené un combat acharné avec la crs
pour avoir ce salaire minimum une
directive sur les salaires ministre vous
êtes séduit dans ses directives c'est un
compromis comme toujours en europe comme
toujours d'ailleurs en général mais
c'est dans ce texte il y a à naître des
éléments chiffrés qu'on a eu beaucoup de
mal à obtenir 60% du salaire médian 50%
du salaire moyen il y a
il y à l'obligation d'obtenir un taux de
couverture des salariés des collègues de
couverture collective pour les salariés
devaient payer 2 81% il ya une forme
d'incitation ça va de sarah permet de
quoi cette directive ça va permettre que
nos mes camarades tchèque bulgares
roumains et ses
filiations à la plaine un levier pour
agir auprès de leur gouvernement et donc
c'est une avancée est ce qu elle est
merveilleuse mayala merveilleux non y'a
quand même se semblait 12 millions
d'européens qui vivent encore sous ses
biens et bien c'est une avancée c'est
une avancée obtenue par l'abnégation des
organisations syndicales et de la
confédération européenne des syndicats
maintenant est ce que c'est la fin de
l'histoire il n'ya pas de fin l'histoire
il n'ya pas de fin de l'histoire c'est à
dire que c'est les organisations
syndicales dans ces pays qui vont devoir
se battre avec nous en soutien pour
obtenir des salaires minimums à la
hauteur justement donc c'est une avancée
je le dis c'est une avancée moi j'en ai
assez qu'on crache sur l'europe en
permanence j'en ai assez c'est notre
horizon et nos solutions et donc là sur
le salaire minimum on aurait souhaité
plus moi je suis un syndicaliste on
aurait souhaité plus mais on s'est battu
et je suis content du que ce combat
justement comment est-ce que la
confédération européenne des syndicats
peu pesé où arrivent à peser au niveau
européen on n'avait pas d'un siège par
exemple consultatif non mais on a enfin
une action de cons acompte d'un mot par
un mot qu on avoue qu'on connaît
beaucoup au niveau européen qui est là
qui sont de lobbying on est beaucoup
auprès des commissaires des
gouvernements pendant la présidence
française de l'union européenne qui est
encore en cours je le rappelle même si
c'est ça c'est quand même beaucoup
percuté avec les échéances électorales
c'est dommage mais on se bat on s'est
battu sur cette directive salaire
minimum sur les quais de la transparence
salariale on a des leviers d'action on
la destine à des sommets exemple
statut plus formalisé moi je serais pour
que formaliser davantage le dialogue
social est au niveau européen qu'il y
ait du temps de jacques delors y avait
les entretiens de val duchesse lésée
l'epl partenaires sociaux se
confrontaient et faisait sortir des
propositions aujourd'hui on a un
patronat qui est trop rétifs au niveau
européen pour entrer dans cette logique
là un peu comme un peu partout
d'ailleurs je les solutions elles
s'imposent pas mais on a des défis qui
sont devant l'europe ils sont immenses
la russie est dans l'écologie qui sont
sociaux ils sont en termes énergétiques
également echos' carbone avec la taxe
carbone bien entendu on a vu avec la
crise en ukraine la guerre en ukraine
combien ce marché de l'énergie européen
fonctionnait pas très bien est ce que
vous vous seriez favorable est ce que
vous pensez que ce marché européen
l'ouverture à la concurrence n'a pas été
une bonne chose finalement ça fait plus
de mal que de bien en tout cas il faut
de la régulation ou à bien qu'en ce
moment ça peut pas être le marché qui
règle qui règle tous les problèmes donc
il ya un problème autour cette ouverture
à la concurrence il n'a pas fait que du
bien moi je crois que l'europe elle doit
avoir des politiques communes au niveau
énergétique au niveau de la défense même
aujourd'hui
un amendement au congrès sur le sujet et
elle doit aussi être moins naïve et se
protéger et se protéger y compris
économique moi je pense que les camps
vous voyager partout dans le monde on
vous dit que l'europe est quand même une
espèce de modèles sur la question
sociale quand vous parlez aux autres
organisations syndicales et puis aussi
sur la question démocratique alors il ya
bien des défauts on les connaît à nos
défauts mais je pense que c'est bon que
ce qu'on doit s'imposer comme règles
sociales et écologiques il faut qu'on la
pose dans nos échanges commerciaux les
clauses miroir c'est fondamental et donc
c'est là dessus il faut y aller sur la
taxe carbone
le projet a été rejeté par les
eurodéputés il est aussi bien critiqué
par les verts les sociaux démocrates et
par les industriels qui pensent que ça
va faire perdre des millions d'emploi
est-ce que c'est aussi quelle est votre
analyse sur scène je pense qu'à un
moment donné si on le fait aux
frontières de l'europe à terme il faudra
voir sa montée en puissance des acteurs
bande à terme c'est absolument
nécessaire c'est à dire qu'il faudra
qu'on impose aujourd'hui on sait bien
que c'est pas de l'europe que dépend
seulement la question climatique et donc
il faudra qu'on impose notre vision de
la transition juste à l'ensemble mais
vous comprenez vous les industriels
qu'ils disent est pas une c'est pas la
bonne solution parce que
je comprends les inquiétudes y compris
des travailleurs nous on a travaillé sur
la filière automobile par exemple avec
une ong fnh et on a montré qu'il fallait
aller vers les véhicules a pu mettre un
véhicule thermique mais il faut
accompagner les travailleurs faut
accompagner des industries et et si on
ne le fait pas ce qui pose devant nous
c'est la survie de l'humanité est ce que
l'écologie ça fait peur justement aux
travailleurs pas forcément je crois
qu'il faut arrêter d'opposer c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec notre association
notre alliance le pack du pouvoir de
vivre avec des ong environnementales des
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
je pense qu'il faut qu'on marie les
enjeux sociaux et les hors jeu et
écologique ça va de pair n'y aura pas
d'emplois sur une planète mordre n'y
aura pas de protection sociale y aura
pas de retraite sur une planète morte
donc c'est ça concerne aussi les
travailleurs qu'ils en sont pleinement
conscientes laurent berger comment vous
faites vous donc leader de la cfdt quand
vous voyez deux déclarations qui sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes entre eux par
exemple bruno le maire sur le chèque
alimentaire qui dit aucune proposition
de ce chaque alimentaire ne tient la
route pour l'instant il avait deux
bornes qui dit qu'elle veut vie réelle
ces montants là directement sur les
comptes en banque vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir entre un premier ministre issu de
la gauche une première ministre sud à
gauche et un mix de l'économie issu de
la droite déjà des petits tiraillements
est ce que vous les noter déjà
on les lit comme tout le monde
s'inquiète on en fait peu de cas moi
vous savez aux deux jeux leur a remis
des propositions la cgt sur tous les
sujets maintenant ce qui m'importe c'est
à chaque fois je vais y revenir ils
connaissent ma constance je moi ils me
connaissent ma détermination et la
combativité mais vous percevez ça quand
même c'est différent on les perçoit en
permanence je vais vous dire c'est pas
nouveau pour le coup c'est pas nouveau
on a toujours perçu ça dans un
gouvernement l'image de la france vous
en parlait il ya un instant à propos du
syndicat européen 20 % des personnels de
charles de gaulle paris charles de
gaulle aéroport sont en grève au moment
où fond la crise du coc vide prend fin
ou les compagnies aériennes vont tenter
d'avoir un été à peu près normale ça
vous inquiète pas ça cette image de la
france oui mais ces cinq slovaque est il
est bloqué rim a sienne c'est aussi les
conditions de travail les conditions
salariales de ses sept salariés à
l'autre l'autre est bien sûr mais vous
savez les choses oui mais on prend
toujours en cours vous savez la cfdt
elle l'a jamais été l'adepte des
mouvements de grève la veille des congés
raid et des congés etc mais il faut
entendre des deux côtés là ce qui se
passe parfois dans les aéroports c'est
une difficulté de recrutement c'est des
conditions de travail extrêmement
dégradée et des salariés qui sont des
sérails la soute issoudun france où 13
salles de bain oui c'est la vitrine de
la france ça serait bien est ce vous
savez on connaît bien dans bien des
endroits dans le monde il ya des belles
vitrines et derrière il ya de la misère
et et je crois pas que ce soit
satisfaisant quand on voyage et donc je
pense que il faut écouter les
revendications de ces travailleurs qui
sont ceux de la sous traitance et c'est
des milliers et des dizaines de milliers
de travailleurs et évidemment il faut
éviter au maximum les perturbations et
là dessus on est on est totalement
d'accord mais faut pas oublier que
derrière il ya des revendications et que
celle ci quand elles sont pas le juste
on peut le dire mais que celle ci ils
sont juste l'affrontement constants
c'est une une solution nommée la cfdt
elle est ni dans l'affrontement
constants ni la france dans la dent là
on est dans le nid dans l'opposition et
dans la majorité on est on est au
service du tram des travailleurs est un
peu au service du pays je crois que on a
une parole à apporter qui est un peu
plus large que la parole syndical pour
dire attendez qu'on arrête un peu nos
conneries de soute sur la gueule en
permanence et c'est ce qu'on essaie de
construire les politiques qui
conviennent bien aux citoyens et aux
travailleurs et ça se passe au niveau
national et ça se passe dans les
territoires merci laurent berger
secrétaire général de la cfdt d'avoir
été invité de face aux territoires ce
matin sur tv5 monde on se retrouve
évidemment jeudi prochain à la même
heure les programmes continuent sur
cette chaîne au revoir à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]